sometimes playing hype music will get me
in the zone oh yeah
nice funk
dude like power of music man like that
that [ __ ] can easily hide
what do you like but how do you know
what music to pick how do you know what
music to pick
i i i let youtube
trying to understand what is emotions
are this is how my music tastes works
and how i find songs i like one song and
then i'll just
keep letting youtube suggest me songs
and i'll keep building i never like
actively look out for songs i just let
it suggest
like youtube and spotify recommendations
were built for people like you dude
they're amazing man it's really [ __ ]
good though i i used to i was die hard
spotify for like six years maybe longer
and then i just tried youtube music once
because i had it with premium yeah and i
was like holy [ __ ] i think i
think i like this more oh dude but i've
discovered so much good music through
spotify
recommended i think on spotify yeah you
should be fine
because they have a lot of there's a lot
of songs that aren't official that
you'll get on youtube music that are
like
remixes that yeah will never be on
spotify because they wouldn't oh i
didn't really give a [ __ ] about the
remix there's so many good ones there's
like one
where it's like uh the sort of chinos
mixed with like that 90s song by like
diana ross or something
that [ __ ] claps man i'll i'll i'll send
you a link there's always the good anime
remakes
there's so many good anime releases on
youtube that you're not allowed on
spotify
right yeah and like because sometimes i
want to listen to like daft punk but i
also want to have
you know that anime remixes yeah yeah so
i can do that on youtube
hell yeah dude i've recently kind of
gone into the rabbit hole of
the these insane like music remixes and
and not just like anime obviously you
know that anime remixes like everyone's
seen the [ __ ] ran a circulation room
yeah yeah yeah
or whatever right my friend sent me one
the other day which was [ __ ] insane
it was
september by earth wind and fire oh
remixed with crazy train by ozzy
osbourne
you couldn't remix that song with
anything though yeah but it sounded
[ __ ] amazing i was like oh my god i
need more i need more i have never seen
an earth wounded fire remix
uh september that disappointed me except
for the taylor swift one that was
terrible
but earth winning fire goes in
everything that we that we shop one have
you seen that the wii
shop bro that [ __ ] collapsed bro
[Music]
i've recently fallen into the rabbit
hole of just listening to j-pop that's
they sound like anime opening and
endings but they're not
oh yeah yeah like polka dots
um it's it's it's it's so many yeah
there's
it's like the rabbit hole right you
discover one the algorithm's like oh oh
you like this
oh hello hello let me let me show you
more it's going so deep right
that recently i was recommended a video
which is kind of like a it was kind of
like a vocaloid kind of remix but i
think it was original song but
the video had no title yeah and the
channel
the channel had no title and then i
click on it what yeah yeah yeah
so so it's it's it's not it's not even
like the they have a space or something
no there's just literally no character
for the title
you even do that apparently you can
there's a there's a thing called like a
a half half space or something and it's
a space that
uh is technically a character yeah but
it doesn't show up as anything
oh wow so so but but you can't you can't
like highlight it and copy and paste
into the search bar
there's no interaction with whatever
character they're putting down right
right
so the only way people would have got
this
is through recommendations yeah and the
video has like two million views it's
[ __ ] insane it's a [ __ ] guitar and
then you click i click on it
right and then everyone's like ah
welcome to the cult
i see you i know i i see you have been
the chosen one
and it's it's it's great because like
they're probably going to kill me now
because it was like everyone's like
mutually agreed not to talk about this
which
sorry guys i guess i guess the entire
the entire [ __ ]
the entire [ __ ] internet knows now
but i'm not going to link to it if if
you're part
if you're part of the chosen one like
show
show me a message if i see anyone
linking it i'm gonna [ __ ] ban you
you played me this at your house and i
was just hoping one day it would pop up
in my record
still waiting still waiting still wait
it's like illuminati man you just gotta
wait for that
crappy vocal or something so maybe it'll
pop up dude